bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg
dans veut cette nouvelle édition
d'europe est de votre rendez vous de
l'actualité européenne dans cette
émission
direction le portugal payant crise
depuis des années certes mais aussi un
des meilleurs élèves en termes
d'énergies renouvelables éolienne
hydraulique biomasse photovoltaïque
aujourd'hui 70 % de l'électricité
consommée est d'origine verte alors le
virage écologique lusitanien est-il
généralisable quelle politique
énergétique pour l'europe de demain
nous en débattrons avec nos invités mais
d'abord l'actualité fumée blanche au
parti populaire européen qui a désigné
jean claude juncker l'ancien premier
ministre du luxembourg comme candidat à
la commission européenne et la faiseuse
de roi n'est autre que la chancelière
allemande alors le ppe est il sous
l'emprise d'un gala merkel c'est la
question de la semaine
ça y est le parti populaire a voté
enfants finalement on attendait plus que
face à face michel barnier commissaire
européen et jean-claude mon coeur
l'éternel premier ministre du luxembourg
aujourd'hui déchu finalement c'est le
luxembourgeois qui l'emportent avec plus
de 60% des suffrages
après avoir été président de
l'eurogroupe pendant des années le voilà
donc candidat au titre de président de
la commission européenne
ou peut-être du conseil européen accéder
au fauteuil de candidats ce grand
monsieur du grand duché peut remercier
angela merkel la faiseuse de roi un vote
tu met sur la touche michel barnier ou
pas alors en gala merkel appelle la
mainmise sur le ppe
et pour répondre à cette question c'est
joseph daul que je reçois bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes président
donc nouvellement réélu du parlement du
ppe et du groupe ppe au parlement
européen donc du parti populaire
européen
vous étiez donc à dublin ces derniers
jours alors répondre directement à cette
question est ce que c'est en gala merkel
finalement elle accéder ou allemande qui
dirige ce parti un peu sourire quand
j'étais mon ma première réunion comme
monsieur martens est décédé oui ma
première réunion s'était engueulé merkel
et vendront punk qui me disait il faut
pas de candidat pour le ppe il faut pas
de candidat carrément ça c'était là et
moi j'ai rappelé simplement ce que nous
avions voté à bucarest au niveau du
parti et j'ai dit moi je suis là pour
faire appliquer les règles qui ont été
votées par un congrès donc et ça prouve
que je les était appliquée jusqu'au bout
oui mais alors jusqu'à la dernière
minute on a quand même poussé michel
barnier à se retirer pour faire de jean
claude juncker le grand le grand
candidat adoubé par tous bons est-ce que
y'a pas un problème entre guillemets de
d'apprentissage si je puis dire de
démocratie interne au sein du parti
populaire européen alors écouter au
niveau du parti populaire européen c'est
le seul parti qui a voté et les délégués
ont choisi leur candidat
non les verts ont voté non mais il y
avait il n'y avait pas 25 candidats chez
les socialistes et chez les libéraux
c'est bien les gens qui comptent six
églises parlement à les verts comptent
aussi donc
donc moi je crois que là haut niveau du
parti d'abord on nous reproche qu'on
n'est pas assez démocrate et pour une
fois que ou et là je remercie michel
barnier que la démocratie a joué
jusqu'au bout il a fait une super bonne
campagne et donc et je peux vous dire
que tous les délégués étaient contents
mais alors justement on voit bien que
jean claude juncker finalement a été mal
élu si je puis dire on s'attendait à un
plébiscite
finalement avec le nombre de suffrages
exprimés on tombe donc de 61 à quasi 40%
il ya quasi 200 délégués sur un peu plus
de six ans qui ne se sont pas exprimés
qui n'ont pas voté
est-ce que c'est pas finalement un peu
un aveu d'échec non il n'y avait pas non
il n'y avait pas de sens il y avait 200
délégués qui n'étaient pas là c'est à
dire si vous avez 80 100 ou 120
boyne par exemple il va envoyer 120
députés à dublin
il ya des partis qui n'ont pas envoyé
120 députés abus blanc parce qu'ils
avaient 120 voire donc les délégués qui
étaient présents tous voter le jour
avant pour mon élection et ce jour là
parce que les gens sont encore arrivé le
premier jour les délégués qui étaient là
ont tous voté et on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui que les gens ne sont pas
venus au congrès ça c'est faux le
problème donc là en l'occurrence c'est
que jean claude juncker n'a pas fait
vraiment l'unanimité on parle de lui
comme d'un dinosaure il est dans les
instances européennes il a été
négociateur du traité de maastricht
il a été donc président de l'eurogroupe
pendant des années premier ministre du
grand duché du luxembourg pendant 18 ans
ce qui n'a pas un problème
et surtout il a toujours été un petit
peu le si je puis dire le défenseur des
paradis fiscaux est ce n'est pas un
problème de testing sur notre nom jean
claude juncker on peut pas lui et ne
peut pas lui reprocher ces choses là
mais je voudrais encore une fois donné
aux deux candidats nous avions deux
candidats super européen deux candidats
qui connaissent le fonctionnement de
l'europe et qui connaissent le
fonctionnement de la commission
et ça c'est important pour le parti donc
jean claude juncker est capable de mener
demain à bien comme président de la
commission et de gérer l'europe ça c'est
très important et tous les deux
candidats qui étaient là c'était deux
candidats potentiels c'est simple c'est
ça qui est arrivé
alors justement la force du ppe c'est
d'avoir été capable si je puis dire de
mettre un candidat effectivement à la
présidence de la commission européenne
mais certains pays rechignent encore à
accepter le fait que ce candidat devra
être désigné par les parlementaires
européens et donc adoubé par le conseil
donc c'est à dire les états
comment ça va se passer dans quelques
mois finalement qui va décider madame le
congrès a pris une décision que je vais
faire appliquer après les élections que
le candidat et le groupe qui arrive en
tête sera officiellement nommé président
pour la présidence de la commission
ce à tous les chefs d'état qui était à
ce congrès ont accepté construit ce
cas-là merkel tous les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement ont tenu à vous pouvez
nous assurer que si le président de la
commission d'accord alors justement je
voudrais que
écoute parce que vous allez reçu ioulia
timochenko lors de ce congrès il ya une
autre actualité qui nous occupe depuis
quelques semaines c'est l'ukraine et
hier le président ianoukovitch s'est
exprimé à la télévision je souhaiterais
qu'on écoute
la tune à pau mais je voudrais vous
rappeler que je reste mais le seul
président légitime d'ukraine où est
aussi le chef des armées
je n'ai jamais démissionné je suis en
vie ja je mets pouvoir me n'a pas été
retirée par la constitution c'est au ces
occasions
monsieur dole est ce que le président
ianoukovitch est toujours le président
de l'ukraine pour pour votre parti pour
moi non parce qu'il ya des élections
j'avais proposé au président
ianoukovitch en décembre avant noël de
dire voilà les gens sont dans la rue
il ya un problème de démocratie il faut
refaire des élections et peut-être
peut-être il aurait terrils là j'aurais
eu du respect mais la manière dont
tonnage dont il a géré cette crise
non ce n'est pas la discréditer au nom
de totalement discuter vous avez donc
reçu comme je le disais ioulia
timochenko dont qui sont imposantes
historique si vous dire qui a été
emprisonné durant des années
est ce que vous considérez que c'est
quelqu'un qui peut représenter une
alternative à écouter rien nous avons
nous avons les deux parties en ukraine
donc du centre droit c'est à eux de
décider qui va les représenter aux
prochaines élections timoshenko ici au
congrès à dublin
nos avions nous étions très fiers
d'avoir pu libérer
ioulia timochenko maintenant c'est aux
parties de voir klitschko était là aussi
c'est dans notre rôle vous savez que moi
j'ai 52 partis différents dans mon
groupe donc c'est aux partis et la
responsabilité du parti pouvoir qui se
présentera bien sûr nous faisons tout
pour qu'il n'y ait pas deux candidats ou
au niveau des élections pour le mois de
mai alors on a vu effectivement angela
merkel donc est membre également du ppe
de la td ou et membre du ppe
agir face à la russie dans une tentative
de médiation est ce que l'europe a pas
été complètement éclipsé sur ce dossier
non si vous avez regardé le sommet le
dernier sommet vous oubliez qu'il y
avait un dernier sommet où il y avait
une unité de vues européennes nuit sur
ce qui se passe en numéro salariés un
peu tard c'est que la crise a commencé
en décembre
vous savez ça c'est toujours au niveau
de l'europe quand il ya vingt-huit
membres pour moi c'est vrai vous avez
raison ça va pas assez vite mais j'étais
déjà très content et l'unanimité avec
les anglais c'est pas rien c'est
effectivement déjà une petite victoire
on voit que catherine ashton a quelque
peu été éclipsés sur ce dossier quel est
votre sentiment par rapport au poste de
haut représentant ligne aux rites et nos
représentants et là je voudrais rendre
hommage à catherine ashton même si elle
n'est pas de mon groupe politique
je crois qu'elle a travaillée et là bien
travailler parce que n'oubliez pas ce
poste a été créé à cinq ans oui on avait
quand même un poste auparavant qu'ils
nommaient attendait reste ok mais quand
vous connaissez la diplomatie de chaque
pays et des grands pays européens pour
monter en puissance au niveau de
l'europe ce n'est pas facile et c'est
pas en cinq ans c'est comme si demain je
veux une défense européenne c'est pas en
cinq ans comment mettre la défense
européenne sur arias yeux alors joseph
daul dernière question vous avez annoncé
il ya quelques mois que vous quittiez
cette grande maison que vous connaissez
depuis des années pour rester à la tête
du parti populaire européen
pourquoi cette décision écoutez moi dans
ma vie j'ai toujours fait par dix ou
quinze ans il après j'ai changé donc la
question s'était posée
vu mon jeune âge de 67 à +5 ça fait 72
il y a eu effectivement le décès de vie
fried martens silence sinon peut-être
j'aurais pris une autre décision je
voulais vous très franchement
mais comme wilfried martens deux jours
avant sa mort m'a téléphoné en disant il
je voudrais que toi tu reprennes le
parti et que les délégués pratiquement
m'ont élu donc très fortement m'ont
soutenu je ne peux pas faire les deux
merci
joseph daul d'avoir été avec nous on est
ravi de vous avoir reçu on espère vous
recevoir de nouveau très bientôt nous
direction le portugal ce petit pays dont
on a l'habitude de parler pour la crise
économique qui le secoue depuis des
années et le champion en europe des
énergies vertes 70 % de l'électricité
consommée est d'origine renouvelable
alors à quelques jours d'un sommet
européen consacré à la question et trois
ans après la catastrophe de fukushima
nous avons voulu voir comment cela
s'organise est dans ce petit pays
direction le portugal avec sandra
cerqueira
difficile de les rater elles sont
partout au portugal les éoliennes font
partie du paysage
nous sommes à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de lisbonne
la proximité de l'océan aux fraudes et
vent favorable toute l'année georges ce
qu'elle est exploitant indépendant
il a vu dans l'éolien une énergie
d'avenir quand la production d'énergie
éolienne a sextuplé en cinq ans et
représente aujourd'hui près de 40% de la
consommation nationale d'électricité
c'est le résultat d'un pari politique
pour améliorer notre indépendance
énergétique au portugal
l'arrivée des parcs éoliens n'a pas
suscité d'opposition
le développement massif de l'énergie
éolienne a été bien accueillie car pour
installer les parcs éoliens il a fallu
construire des routes améliorer
certaines infrastructures et cela a aidé
au désenclavement des villages isolés
les communes ont tiré profit de
l'utilisation de leurs terres et cela a
été vu comme une réelle opportunité
une bouffée d'air une opportunité
d'emploi également dans un pays où le
taux de chômage dépasse les 15%
ce marché a permis à beaucoup de
portugais de retrouver le chemin du
travail
ce parc éolien il continue à bien
produire oui et les résultats sont
plutôt bons les techniciens avec
lesquels george de colabor se sont
formés récemment près de 40000 emplois
ou été créé avec les énergies
renouvelables les personnes avec qui je
travaille et qui assure la maintenance
ont suivi des formations de techniciens
en temps de crise c'est ce dont le pays
a besoin
nous avons ainsi pu garder une main
d'oeuvre formée qui sent le secteur du
renouvelable aurait quitté le pays
l'essor du renouvelable à aider à
dynamiser les régions les plus pauvres
grâce à l'implantation d'un tissu
industriel
c'est le cas dans la neige à evora
capitale de la région
bon nombre d'entreprises sont en
difficulté celle-ci spécialisé à
l'origine dans l'aéronautique se porte
bien
depuis qu'elle a misé sur le
photovoltaïque
combien de plaques ont produit
aujourd'hui à peu près 500 à 600 par
heure de nouveaux contrats à la clé plus
d'activités et des embauches
supplémentaires
ce gérant n'imaginais pas que les
énergies vertes pouvait être à ce point
rentable une chose à ses yeux rouges pas
seul au coeur nous sommes mises à
exporter hors des frontières d'europe
il y a deux ans on a exporté vers les
émirats arabes unis puis vers les pays
du golfe
notre entreprise a vraiment pris une
nouvelle dimension
comment expliquer ce miracle le
portugais
par manque d'énergie fossiles ou
nucléaires le pays a toujours été
contraints d'importer alors produire de
l'électricité renouvelable a permis de
faire des économies
jusqu'en 2005 nous importions 85%
énergie consommée cela représentait la
moitié du déficit commercial portugais
c'était intenable pour notre économie
depuis le virage énergétique notre
dépendance extérieure est moins
importante et continue de baisser en
font presque la totalité de
l'électricité consommée en 2013 est
d'origine renouvelable
un cas rare en europe résultat d'une
politique volontariste qui a débuté il
ya près de dix ans l'état a soutenu des
installations en proposant des contrats
qui fixent un tarif de rachat de
l'électricité stable sur 15 ans et ce
afin d'attirer les investisseurs sur ce
nouveau marché
mais avec la crise l'attribution de
nouvelles licences a été gelé cet
ingénieur craint pour le développement
de la filière éolienne au moment où le
pays tente de développer le prototype
d'une nouvelle turbine d'éolien offshore
moins cher et plus efficace
le portugal produit parfois plus qu'il
ne consomme alors le véritable enjeu
selon lui c'est de pouvoir exporter
davantage
l'ibérique est encore considérée comme
une île au sein de l'europe le portugal
et l'espagne sont connectés l'espagne et
la france aussi
mais ce n'est pas suffisant il faudrait
pouvoir exporter jusque dans le centre
de l'europe en développant les
interconnexions entre le portugal et les
autres pays membres pour connaissent
enfin un véritable réseau électrique
européen qui ont manqué
et c'est une demande récente du
gouvernement portugais
persuadé que sans l'achat de la
production d'électricité verte du pays
il sera impossible d'atteindre les 20 7
% d'énergies renouvelables au sein de
l'union européenne
l'objectif fixé par bruxelles pour 2030
et voilà pour ce reportage au portugal
de sandra cerqueira et pour évoquer
cette question je reçois de député avec
moi bonjour beaucoup cela sonne et que
vous êtes député polonais membre du
parti populaire européen et yannick
jadot vous êtes député donc vers fait
quand vous on voit cet exemple en fait
du portugal qui a réussi en fait à
produire quasi 70 % de sa consommation
en énergie verte est ce que vous
considérez que c'est un exemple qui est
généralisable à l'europe entière si je
puis dire un exode au absolument
absolument on voit à la fois des pays
comme la suède tout le nord de l'europe
on voit des pays comme l'allemagne qui
ont fait ce choix d'accélérer la
transition énergétique à la fois parce
qu'il ya un enjeu climatique évident car
on a vu encore tout cet hiver des
tempêtes à répétition dans tout l'ouest
de la france
on voit les premières conséquences des
changements climatiques dont il faut
sortir du carbone et puis on voit
surtout l'intérêt des énergies
renouvelables en termes de création
d'emplois en termes d'aménagement du
territoire à travers 400 milles en
allemagne je veux dire c'est quand même
des secteurs qui créent de l'emploi
alors qu'on voit beaucoup de secteurs
économiques qui en perdent sont des
secteurs qui créent de l'emploi c'est
souvent des emplois qualifiés sont des
emplois non délocalisables
donc on voit bien tout l'intérêt à la
fois environnementales économiques
sociales de cette transition énergétique
sachant que les le développement des
énergies renouvelables ne doit pas non
plus se substituer à une grande
politique d'économie d'énergie on voit
en ukraine on voit avec la précarité
énergétique on voit avec le fait que
l'europe dépense 1 milliard par jour
d'importation d'énergie fossile il faut
économiser l'énergie et il faut faire
des énergies renouvelables beaucoup
savent sonic est ce que vous êtes
d'accord est ce que finalement ce n'est
pas une possibilité plutôt que de rester
dans les nerfs
fossiles que d'aller vers ces énergies
vertes mais quand il faut les deux parce
que pour moment énergies renouvelables
fonctions parce qu'ils ont de
subventions d'état
alors il faut il faut un certain moment
arrêter la subvention subventions et
voir comment ça va fonctionner comme un
con qu'on va avoir une marché libre mais
je suis d'accord qu'il vention vous
dites que en gros les états soutiennent
absolument ces filières donc ses fidèles
ne pourrait pas entre guinée tenir la
route c'est sûr mais par des achats
d'énergie sur le prix fixe
pendant la crise il y a toujours eu le
deuxième problème qu'il faudra toujours
avoir de wergifosse il pour maintenir en
marche même renouvelables parce qu'il
n'ya pas encore la capacité de magazines
de en fait effectivement comme vous le
dites de recherche et développement
autour de la possibilité de stocker
cette électricité
après tout oui bien sûr il faut ce qu'il
faut arriver à stocker l'électricité
c'est un des grands projets industriels
et de recherche
mais ce qu'on voit à travers le portugal
c'est qu'on arrive justement à cet
équilibre dans les énergies
renouvelables parce que
l'hydroélectricité qui n'est pas
intermittente permet de compenser
l'intermittence de l'éolien est l'un des
grands enjeux européens c'est justement
d'avoir des infrastructures énergétiques
bien connecté à l'échelle européenne
pour que quand il ya moins de vent sur
la mer du nord
on profite du soleil sur l'europe du sud
on profite de la biomasse en profitent
des énergies marines alors donc c'est le
là c'est le bouquet énergie mais le
bouquet déstabilise ficultés c'est que
il faut bien aussi transporter cette
électricité c'est quand même des
investissements absolument mais les
transporter l'électricité ou connecter
les régions entre elles
ça coûtera toujours moins cher que de
développer des capacités de production
pour servir les intérêts ou les besoins
locaux
donc il faut à la fois encore une fois
économiser l'énergie
développer les énergies renouvelables
excusez moi mais le rapport de la
commission européenne dit clairement que
en europe les énergies les plus
subventionnés sur les énergies fossiles
après c'est l'énergie nucléaire et après
seulement ce sont des énergies
renouvelables et on sait que les prix
des énergies renouvelables baisse de
manière constante donc c'est des
énergies qui deviennent compétitives
plus de deux tiers des et des capacités
de production électrique installée en
europe ce sont des énergies
renouvelables c'est là où vont les
investisseurs privés
donc si c'est à la fois de la
perspective encore une fois c'est de
l'emploi c'est de la réindustrialisation
est aujourd'hui à l'échelle européenne
on arrive à compenser les intermittences
par exemple intégrer monsieur sonic
écoutez ça ce qui manque dans le propos
de monsieur j'adore c'est le mot
indépendance énergétique ne sont pas
d'accord que on essaye de nous pousser
vers les achats d'énergie qui vient de
pays scandinaves ou de portugal nous
avons besoin avoir indépendance
énergétique parler d'indépendance
énergétique c est à part et house et
pour toute l'union européenne parce
qu'après tout si on pouvait se fournir
de l'aide de l'énergie entre le film et
pour ça il faut construire des nouveaux
l' union européenne sur le base de
solidarité un adjectif comme on a
commencé par les parle d'union de
charbon et de l'acier maintenant il
faudra faire ensemble des achats de ne
pas s que vous seriez pour cette cette
europe de l'énergie je suis beau mais ça
ça va ça va pas se faire tout de suite
d'accord il faut que cette réponse c'est
quoi ces nucléaire c'est le charbon
c'est le gaz de schiste
les mix bien si c'est un cocktail est
explosif à on va quand même reconnaître
exactement vous pouvez les énergies
renouvelables si oui le quartier dioula
parce qu'on participe quand même dans le
grand plan de 20% en 2020
mais ça ce qu'on veut pas qu'on essaye
de nous imposer par le voit
administratif européenne
le but le clisson intenable dans le cas
de la pologne de l'adduction de co2 je
voudrais justement que l'inde est l'une
des personnes que l'on a vu dans ce
reportage avait une question directe à
vous poser je souhaiterais qu'on les
écoute
il ya un manque de coordination entre
les pays membres en ce qui concerne les
énergies renouvelables c'est pourquoi il
est souvent difficile quand on est chef
d'entreprise de se projeter à moyen et
long terme sera ton fixé sur la
stratégie mise en place par bruxelles
pour développer le renouvelable
monsieur celui qui alors justement est
ce que on pourrait être fixée nous
demande cet entrepreneur sur la
stratégie globale de bruxelles sur la
question des énergies renouvelables
d'abord il faut commencer par le pape
par voient comment ça se passe dans
chaque pays il ya une différence
ils sont deux stratégies différentes
dont le dans le pays membres sur
énergies renouvelables et maintenant on
nous pousse encore voilà jusqu'à
augmenter le pourcentage d'énergies
renouvelables et si on regarde la cas de
la france de l'allemagne
il y à certains il ya sept ans les
politiques énergétiques renouvelables
qui sont compromis alors il faut il faut
montrer le meilleur exemple donnant
certitude aux investisseurs alors jean
aussi que ça va pas donc trois ans on va
nous dire non non ça c'est déjà
vieillissent a pas marché oui je voulais
juste de dire que l'union européenne ne
peut pas faire les chevaliers celle sur
cette lutte contre les changements
climatiques nous du côté polonais nous
défendons la
encore accord global avec les états unis
avec les indes avec tous les grands
émetteurs de justement pour rebondir sur
ce que me disait monsieur sonic à quoi
ça sert finalement que l'europe cherche
à descendre ses émissions de gaz à effet
serre de 20% de 30% 40% partir du moment
où la chine ou les états unis refusent
de se plier je dirais à ce qu'ils
considèrent comme un diktat
en même temps si vous voulez faut voir
que la chine agit beaucoup aujourd'hui
sur la question qui visite la chine est
aujourd'hui le plus gros émetteur
mondial
mais dans l'histoire c'est pas la chine
ce qui a déjà dans l'atmosphère c'est
d'abord les états unis et l'europe donc
on a une responsabilité historique
on a aussi une responsabilité historique
à prendre le leadership sur la lutte
contre les changements climatiques pour
entraîner l'ensemble des autres pays de
la planète c'est aussi le rôle
historique de l'europe sur la question
des droits fondamentaux
sur la question de la démocratie il faut
faire c'est à paris que se tient la
grande conférence internationale sur le
climat en 2015 donc il faut que l'europe
soit exemplaire mais là
l'europe est en train de patiner est en
train de s'immobiliser sur son paquet
climat énergie 2030 qui pourrait décider
dans les objectifs pourraient être
décidées au sommet européen
donc c'est 21 mars et on voit
malheureusement que la france et pas
dans le bon camp aujourd'hui la france
veut participer un objectif de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais ne souhaite pas voir un objectif
contraignant fort sur les énergies
renouvelables
parce que la france a pas encore décidé
si elle raccroche vieux monde avec
malheureusement la pologne la grande
bretagne qui ne veulent pas des énergies
renouvelables ou qui veulent surtout
faire du nucléaire du gaz de schiste et
choisir plutôt le camp de l'allemagne
qui c'est un consensus politique
économique d'aller vers les énergies
renouvelables et tout ce que ça of il va
falloir par le charbon quand même non
mais attendez le charbon moi je suis
contre le charbon
oui mais la situation en allemagne
aujourd'hui excusez moi c'est parce que
le charbon et pas cher parce que
l'europe est déficiente sur sa capacité
à taxer le co2 notamment parce que des
pays comme la pologne s'y opposent que
le charbon
il remplace le gaz le charbon ne
remplace pas le nucléaire le nucléaire
remplacé aujourd'hui par les énergies
renouvelables et les et les économies
d'énergie est ce qu'il faut voir
aujourd'hui c'est le combat titanesque
qui en europe aujourd'hui entre un
système où c'est des grandes entreprises
multinationales qui disent pour nous de
l'énergie qui prennent la rente ou comme
en allemagne et ailleurs des citoyens
qui économisent l'énergie et produisent
ensemble et des énergies renouvelables
dont ils ont besoin que je fais pas un
retournement complet du système
énergétique qui se joue mais sessegnon
jeunes à l'art je proteste qu'on
l'apprend daniel aux événements de la
classe vous avez quand même organisé un
sommet du charbon en même temps que le
sommet climatique c'était gonflé quand
même alors monsieur solic dernière
question parce que malheureusement on
arrive à la fin de cette émission
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
conseil européen qui aura lieu sur ce
paquet énergie climat est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à ce que l'europe baisse à
l'horizon 2030 de 40% ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à côté moi je pense
qu'il faut choisir un seul but pense je
pense que 47 euros mais disons 35 et
après chaque pays
sera libre de choisir son propre voix
d'arriver à 7 buts donc pour vous en
faites finale dépendance au pays et
surtout surtout utilisé ça ce qui est ce
que nous nous avons pas d efficacité
énergétique sur ça il ya encore beaucoup
de choses à faire et peut-être un jour
cette europe de l'énergie que vous
prenez effectivement merci monsieur je
suis désolé le temps nous était compté
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
à bruxelles bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires